Ah ! Bonjour à tous, curieuses et curieux ! Ça
vous dirait un petit voyage en Égypte
en mode exploration de cimetières
d'oiseaux momifiés le long du Nil ?
C'est absolument dingue : des millions de
momies d'ibis et d'oiseaux de proie ont
été retrouvées dans des dizaines de temples.
Attendez... Des millions ? Mais pourquoi autant ?
Pour décrypter ce mystère, pas besoin de faire
appel à Indiana Jones. Direction le musée des
Confluences de Lyon : un écrin rempli de momies
animales. 2500 pièces au total ce qui en fait la
plus grande collection du monde (hors territoire
égyptien) ! Vraiment, Harrison Ford peut aller se
rhabiller ! Une équipe de chercheurs lyonnais
en géochimie y a mené l'enquête sur 20 momies
d'oiseaux : 11 momies d'ibis sacrés et neuf rapaces.
Eh oui, l’Égypte ancienne, ses pyramides, ses
temples, ses pharaons et ses momies d'animaux. Les
égyptiens plaçaient l'animal au centre de leur vie.
D'ailleurs, il n'y a qu'à voir leurs dieux, presque
tous représentés sous les traits d'animaux plutôt
cools, comme le faucon, le crocodile, ou la punaise
d'eau. Au fil des années, des millions de momies
d'animaux ont été retrouvées dans des temples:
chats, serpents, lionceaux, gazelles, mais surtout
une quantité incroyable d'oiseaux momifiés entre
-700 et 300 après Jésus Christ. Si les momies nous
font rêver, à l'époque cela représentait plutôt
un énorme business. On sait que certains animaux,
comme les chats, étaient élevés pour être sacrifiés
momifiés et vendus au peuple. Mais revenons à nos
momie d'oiseaux : leur présence sur les sites
archéologiques est absolument écrasante. On
y trouve principalement des ibis et des rapaces,
sacrifiés pour honorer plusieurs divinités à tête
de piafs. On sait qu'à l'époque, de grandes chasses
aux oiseaux étaient organisées dans la nature
pour les capturer, mais quelques mystères planaient
encore sur leurs origines : comment savoir si ces
millions de momies étaient le fruit d'un business
de volatiles élevés pour être momifiés, ou s'ils
étaient majoritairement issus d'une chasse
à l'état naturel, ce qui aurait pu avoir un
impact sur leurs populations sauvages. Et c'est
là qu'interviennent nos experts en géochimomie... Euh...
Géochimie. Et pour cette étude, les scientifiques
se sont penchés sur la signature de ces oiseaux.
Mais non, pas celle au stylo, mais bien leur
signature isotopique, c'est-à-dire, en gros,
les variations de divers éléments chimiques, qui
peuvent renseigner sur leur provenance, notamment.
Il est donc possible, en explorant cette signature,
d'obtenir des informations sur l'alimentation et
l'environnement des oiseaux. On peut y retrouver
des traces de sédiments, par exemple, ou fouiller
dans les proportions d'isotopes d'éléments
chimiques comme l'oxygène, l'azote, le soufre
ou le carbone. Et tout ça va nous donner de sacrés
indices pour élucider notre mystère ; c'est un peu
la carte d'identité de leur régime alimentaire.
Grâce aux isotopes stables de l'oxygène, il est
possible de déterminer l'origine de l'eau que les
oiseaux buvaient à l'époque, et dont les signatures
sont préservées dans leurs hôtes des milliers
d'années plus tard. Et forcément, les animaux
sauvages n'ont pas du tout le même régime qu'en
captivité. Si on faisait la même chose avec nos
volailles élevées en batterie et des volailles
sauvages, la différence de diète serait flagrante.
Pour cette étude, il était important d'avoir
un point de départ et de comparaison, afin de
croiser les résultats et pour ça les scientifiques
sont allés chercher cette fois-ci la signature
isotopique de momies du peuple de l'époque,
car la momification n'était pas un processus
exclusivement réservé aux pharaons. Franchement
depuis que les prix de la momification ont flambé,
c'est décidé, je m'auto-momifie, voilà.
Lesprofils isotopique de ces momies humaines ont
révélé une diète homogène et locale, avec une
consommation d'eau et de nourriture produite
le long de la vallée du Nil et finalement peu
diversifiée. Pour commencer, les chercheurs ont
utilisé un protocole chimique permettant d'isoler
les molécules présentes dans les fragments d'os
et de plumes : un processus délicat, et à l'échelle
microscopique, mais rassurez-vous, aucune momie n'a
été maltraitée pendant la manipulation. Une fois les
signatures isotopiques obtenues sur nos 20 momies,
les chercheurs ont constaté que les oiseaux
de proie avait une diète bien plus diverse
que celle des humains. Ils ne passaient donc pas
l'essentiel de leur temps dans la vallée du Nil,
et migraient ponctuellement dans d'autres régions.
Le verdict tombe alors, ces oiseaux de proie étaient
chassés à l'état sauvage pour être ensuite momifiés
et offerts aux dieux. Concernant les ibis, les
résultats sont un peu différents. Leur régime
est plus varié que celui des humains, mais les
signatures sont typiques des environnements du Nil.
Pas d'élevage, donc. Les populations de ces oiseaux
devaient rester le long du cours du Nil et migraient
peut-être saisonnièrement plus en amont, mais
difficile de savoir s'ils vivaient en semi-liberté
ou à l'état sauvage. Dans tous les cas, il est
intéressant de comprendre si cette industrie de
la momification a eu un impact sur ces populations
d'oiseaux, surtout quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
on ne trouve plus d'ibis dans la vallée du Nil.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, et qu'il
aura su faire ressortir votre âme de géochimistes !
N'hésitez pas à nous laisser un commentaire, un
pouce bleu, et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner !
Eh ! Attends ! Reviens, là, tu t'es même pas abonné !